parce que nos villes se transforment
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux
iprema votre partenaire pour un
développement
durable je t'écris ces quelques lignes
pour te dire que oui je suis prêt à
faire un petit bout de chemin avec toi
PS quand je parle de bout de chemin je
veux dire départ de chez moi arriver au
boulot puis retour maison si possible
tous les jours merci à toi le
covoiturage c'est convivial économique
et écologique avec le covoiturage
Saint-Quentin en Yveline vous propose
une nouvelle façon de vous déplacer les
inscriptions et les infos sur
www.covoiturage.aglo-sqy.fr
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d'équilibre au sommaire
ce mois-ci saviez-vous que les golfs
affili à la Fédération Française de Golf
sont obligés de respecter certaines
normes environnementales c'est ce que
nous verrons tout à l'heure avec le
green keeper du Golf National
Saint-Quentin en yeline à suivre
également de nouveau la tzie et oui on
narrête pas d'en parler nous sommes
allés à la rencontre d'un betta testeur
du système d'autopartage mise en place
par la Communauté d'Agglomération de
SaintQuentin en Yveline nous irons
ensuite au front avec le collectif de
réappropriation de l'espace public de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline qui souhaite
réimplanter des plantes en ville mais
sans plus attendre alors que le taux de
chômage en France atteint des records
certaines entreprises ont du mal à
pourvoir des emplois c'est le cas de la
société vert d'cho de maniéamoau qui ne
sait plus quoi faire pour trouver du
personnel regardez temps de crise la
crise une crise au sein de la zone euro
une crise une crise c'est le paradoxe de
cette crise la crise est partout et
pourtant elle ne semble pas toucher vers
d'cho une PME manioise qui affiche un
chiffre d'affaires de 4 millions7 mais
l'entreprise rencontre un autre problème
elle peine à trouver de la main d'œuvre
on n pas de problème financier c'est une
entreprise qui se porte bien on a une
progression de Chi d'affaires de 5 à 15
% suivant les années par exemple l'année
dernière en 2011 on a fait 13 %
d'augmentation de chifaffairire
l'enseigne créer entretient des paysages
extérieurs et intérieurs pour les
entreprises et les particuliers
elle possède également deux boutiques de
fleurs en ville et un bureau d'études
tous ces employés sont en CDI à titre
d'exemple un ouvrier paysagiste débutant
gagne entre 1400 et 1800 € avec un
avantage certain la possibilité de
piquer une tête entre deux commandes
mais malgré cela impossible de recruter
on met en place des des annonces hein po
l'emploi les écoles notre site internet
mais par exemple pour chercher un
chiffreur mtreur euh pour nos devis pour
construire un peu nos devis on n pas de
CV et maintenant les les les formations
vont aller au-delà de des postes de
jardinier sur le terrain et on va
trouver plus facilement des postes
d'encadrant que des postes d'ouvriers
sur le terrain le gérant de ver Descours
recherche 5 personnes pour permettre à
son entreprise d'évoluer si aucun
ouvrier paysagiste fleuriste chiffreur
mreur ou responsable de production ne
vient à lui c'est lui qui ira vers eux
les solutions es sont elles sont
multiples et soit on essaie de trouver
des gens qui ont peu d'expérience et on
va les for for tout au long de leur
carrière pour les faire évoluer dans le
dans le métier donc ça c'est une
solution qu'on est en train de
travailler de manière beaucoup plus
forte que les années précédentes ou
alors retrouver des gens qui veulent
changer de métier et et donc il sont
attirés par le métier de paysage et on a
quelques personnes qui sont en
reconversion professionnelle dans notre
entreprise le cas d'Olivier bedouel
n'est pas isolé les métiers du paysage
vivent une profonde mutation et et les
demandes en recrutement sont fortes
entre 2008 et 2010 le nombre
d'entreprises paysagères a augmenté de
%. le métier de Green keepeper vous
connaissez mais si voyons ce sont ces
personnes qui sont chargées d'entretenir
les parcours de golf c'est un métier
méconnu qui demande pourtant une
formation extrêmement poussée qui leur
permet notamment de repérer une maladie
sur les terrains qu'ils entretiennent à
partir d'une simple petite araignée
impressionnant non ces personnes sont
également chargées de veiller au respect
des normes environnementales c'est ce
que nous avons appris avec ce green
keeper que nous avons rencontré à
l'occasion de l'Open de golf Alstom
regardez gérud doyot est l'intendant du
parcours de l'Albatros au Golf National
SaintQuentin en yeline à Guill encour
les passionnés de golf connaissent sa
fonction sous un autre nom green keeper
son rôle s'assurer que le terrain
corresponde aux règles imposées par
l'europeéan tour l'instance chargée de
gérer le tournoi de l'Open de France qui
se déroule du 5 au 8 juillet d'une
manière générale ce qui est recherché
c'est d'avoir des Green les plus fermes
possibles ce qu'on appelle des Green
tambour avec une réponse de la balle qui
va rebondir à l'impact ce qui rend plus
sélectif le l'attaque des Green après
cette année la tendance et la
particularité ça a été rendre les
faerway les plus rectilignes possibles
de manière à pas pénaliser les joueurs
suivant s' tomb dans un même axe des
longueurs différentes et par contre on a
rétréci leur largeur qui a été porté à
des largeurs inférieur à 25 m au total
ce qui présente des couloirs assez
étroits préparer un terrain requiert une
palette de compétences extrêmement large
parmi lesquels une connaissance des
normes environnementales on essaie de
faire des actions sur plusieurs points
un c'est maîtriser les fertilisant qu'on
met savoir plus on en met plus le gazon
est sensible et peut devenir malade donc
on fait vraiment par rapport à ses
besoin après on essaie de préserver des
quelques endroits avec de la
biodiversité pour favoriser installation
de d'une faune et d'une flore un peu
atypique à noter également un usage
raisonné de l'eau en 2006 la Fédération
Française de Golf a signé une charte
visant à réduire de 40 % la consommation
de tous les terrains de l'Hexagone le
Golf National 501 en Yveline est passé
de 170000 M C annuels à 90000 M C selon
géraudoyot le mois de juin plusvieux a
contribué à économiser de grandes
quantités d'eau cette année pendant
toute la durée de l'Open pas de repos
pour le green keepeper il doit se
préparer aux pires situations parmi
lesquelles une maladie subite qui
pourrait détruire le green en moins de
24 heures ou encore de violents
orages et non ça c'était avant
maintenant c'est fini ça serait plutôt
quelque chose de ce
style-là avec peut-être une petite
pointe
de qu'est-ce que j'imite mais la TE bien
sûr on en a parlé à plusieurs reprises
dans équilibre la tezy un véhicule
électrique qui est actuellement en
circulation dans les rues de
Saint-Quentin dans le cadre d'un test
d'autopartage alors nous sommes allés à
la rencontre d'un bet testeur les BET
testurs sont des cinquantinois qui
testent actuellement ces véhicules
demain ce sera peut-être vous impression
vous l'avez sans doute croisé dans les
rues de Saint-Quentin en Yveline Renault
poine le lancement de son service
d'autopartage électrique prévu pour la
rentrée actuellement 200 cl expériment
la twzie dans l'agglomération Pierre
Rousseau habite à voisin le Bretonneux
il fait partie des BTA testeurs de ce
véhicule atypique je préfère utiliser
tezy parce que je trouve que le
déplacement est beaucoup plus fun dans
tezy que que dans nos voitures
habituelles c'est c'est une bonne tenue
de route un freinage un peu léger
peut-être mais une bonne tenue de route
mais c'est pas fait pour le but il est
pas d'essayer de de batre d'core le but
ilessayer de rouler écolo et de de faire
avancer des nouveaux modes de
déplacement sur la ville nouvelle les
testeurs peuvent réserver une voiture et
savoir où elle se trouve via une
application sur leur smartphone pour
louer une twzie il suffit de flasher son
code barre valider sa location avec sa
carte d'abonnement et suivre les
instructions de la voiture et Pierre
Rousseau peut partir le cœur léger
pendant la durée des tests le parking
est gratuit dans toute l'agglomération
et Renault s'occupe de tout les clients
prennent la voiture où elle se trouveve
et ensuite la restitue là où il le
souhaite dans la zone de service et
c'est nous qui surveillons la le niveau
de charge des batteries et qui allons
les chercher pour les remplacer ensuite
par des tis chargés les testeurs payent
le service à un prix tarifaire
privilégié par rapport au au tarifs que
nous aurons à la rentrée la tisier est
destiné un usage de proximité un permis
de motocyclette est suffisant pour la
conduire elle ne dépasse pas les 90 km/h
alors interdiction d'aller sur autoroute
les plus c'est que c'est électrique donc
c'est non polluant c'est maniable ça se
gare facilement
l'avantage c'est que les places sont
gratuites pour l'instant jusque je crois
septembre puisque il y a un partenariat
donc on paye pas de stationnement les
moins bah c'est dans certaines certaines
communes on trouve pas beaucoup de
véhicules donc il faut marcher pas mal
pour avoir un véhicule cet été les
testeurs payent une adhésion de 10 € et
10 centimes la minute soit 6 € de
l'heure pour participer deux critères
avoir son permis de conduire depuis plus
de 2 ans et vivre dans l'agglomération
et si vous n'avez pas eu l'occasion de
tester la TI pendant les vacances
rendez-vous à la rentrée pour le
lancement officiel de l'autopartage à
cquanttin en
Yveline attention la Guer jardinière est
déclaré les soldats du collectif de
réappropriation de l'espace public de
SaintQuentin en ivline font la guerre au
béton comment tout simplement en
plantant des graines et des arbres un
peu partout dans Saint-Quentin en
Eveline regardez ça on a organisé une
journée de réappropriation de l'espace
public donc le but c'était de réaliser
différentes actions des actions comme là
on est en train de le faire de guirilla
gardening donc pour végétaliser la ville
donc là c'est des actions à long terme
parce qu'on va pas se contenter de semer
comme ça et puis de plus revenir ça
demande un peu de suivi la gueria
jardinière une action directe qui
consiste à planter et semer dans
l'espace public une pratique qui nous
vient du Japon directement inspirée par
la permaculture la permaculture ça
consiste à faire de l'agriculture en
intervenant le moins possible sur la
nature en laissant la nature prendre le
dessus et par exemple ne pas retourner
la terre et compagnie étant donné que on
a de plus en plus de béton dans la ville
et voilà donc c'est plus sympa d'avoir
des fleurs des plants et c'est aussi le
côté de de dire qu'on a ce qu'il faut en
fait pour manger porter demain quoi si
on a des arbres fruitiers objectif
esthétique écologique et donc pratique
ce jour-là le crêpe avait également
organisé une balade citoyenne pour
promouvoir les transports non polluants
nom de code vélo
rtion une initiative suivie d'un repas
partagé de débat et d'intervention
politique du collectif vélodrame contre
l'implantation du Vélodrome à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline il s'agissait
de la deuxième journée de ce type
organisée sur l'agglomération le crêp de
sa-quentin en Yveline espère bien
mensualiser l'initiative dès septembre
prochain et pas question de se quitter
sans le traditionnel agenda pour les
passionnés de jardin à la française je
vous propose de découvrir ce de
Versailles jusqu'au 23 octobre et vous
allez le découvrir en musique et enfin
n'hésitez pas à faire un tour du côté de
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
pour les Jeux d'été trait des vaches
labyrinthe de maïs ou encore piscine de
paille tout un programme voilà équilibre
c'est fini pour cette saison on se
retrouve le mois prochain pour de
nouvelles aventures d'ici là portez-vous
bien ciao
bye